hey what is up guys MTV HD here so what
makes a good smartphone camera it's just
you know more megapixels is better right
no no all right so the sensor the sensor
is the most important piece of hardware
when it comes to image quality there are
good sensors there are bad sensors there
are different types of sensors and there
are large sensors there are small
sensors and everything in between it's
hard to tell a lot about an image sensor
just by the name or the numbers but
there's one thing that pretty much
always rings true which is that when all
other things are held constant a larger
sensor can outperform a smaller one now
the camera sensors and smartphones are
pretty much always tiny not tiny enough
to get rid of the camera bump that we
still have in like 99% of smart phones
these days but obviously a lot smaller
than your normal point shoots so your
smartphone cameras have to rely on their
own tricks to make great pictures you
might remember HTC's attempt at an ultra
pixel camera back in 2013 a 4 megapixel
camera that claimed to be much better at
a lot of things including low-light
here's why a sensor is a piece of
hardware responsible for turning all the
light that hits it into electrical
signals and you can kind of think of it
like a grid of pixels the larger the
sensor obviously the larger the pixels
and the more sensitive it can be to
light but all these smart phone sensors
are all pretty tiny so HTC instead went
with way less pixels so that the
individual pixels are much larger for
better low-light performance now 4
megapixels is still enough to have a
decent amount of detail if you don't
zoom in at all but most of the time we
see smartphones at the other end of the
spectrum with 12 16 18 megapixel sensors
which gives you a ton of detail but
obviously they will suffer a little bit
more in low-light alright so in front of
the sensor is all the glass and all the
lenses through which light has to pass
to hit the sensor aside from the quality
of the glass the speck that matters the
most here is the aperture smartphone
cameras are all fixed aperture lenses
and generally the bigger the better
because the more light you can let in so
the best smartphone cameras now have F
2.0 sometimes even F 1.9 or F 1.8
apertures which
is great for letting like I said a ton
of light in and also getting a little
bit of separation between your
foreground and background or the shallow
depth-of-field one thing that is hit or
miss is stabilization so software
stabilization or EIS is decent for
correcting a little bit of minor
handshake if you get a little bit of
blur it's good at removing that and not
having that in images but in video
content to have a little bit of a jello
effect but hardware stabilization or oh
is is awesome
pretty much all the time it's much
better for having longer exposures and
while having shaky hands can still
produce very sharp images it's better
for low-light and it can produce much
much smoother video not every smartphone
uses OIS and not every sensor is even
compatible with it but when it is
possible it's preferred now aside from
that you don't really need to pay too
much attention to like the number of
lens elements that number has been
boasted about before but doesn't really
tell you too much about the quality of
the camera and the flash design I
wouldn't pay too much attention to that
either sometimes you can get something
interesting like a ring flash or a dual
LED flash or even a xenon flash but for
the most part I avoid using a flash with
smart phone pictures in the first place
anyway and from there it all comes down
to processing every smartphone camera
processes the images that come from that
sensor a little bit differently some do
a little bit more sharpening some do
less some do a little bit more noise
reduction and some do a little bit less
some shift towards warmer colors some
shift towards cooler colors some crank
up the saturation others keep it pretty
tame some favour a bright exposure some
keep it a little bit underexposed but
the one thing about photos is it's all
subjective so you might have a
smartphone that takes an objectively
more accurate photo and then another one
that takes a little bit less accurate
but also more pleasing to the eye photo
like for example my buddy Casey nice tat
on Twitter he did a blind test where he
took the same photo with the Nexus 6p
and the iPhone 6s the Nexus 6p gave you
know much cooler colors and a much
brighter some might even say overexposed
image but it won the popular vote
because it just kind of looked a little
better to people despite being less
accurate than the shot from the iPhone
so final word it's really hard to tell
how good a smartphone camera will be
just by the numbers just kind of like
it's hard to tell how well a car will
drive by the
spec's on paper you don't really know
until you actually drive it you can get
a good idea and a reviewer can tell you
how accurate the photos will be and
whether there are certain tendencies in
processing but that stuff can be changed
with a software update anyway so at the
end of the day it's you who will tell
how good a smartphone camera is just
based on how much you like the picture
so that's basically it thank you for
watching hopefully this gives you a
better idea of what I'm talking about
when I go deep into camera quality and
the phone reviews and are more reviews
right around the corner so thank you for
watching this one I'll talk to you guys
in the next video peace